hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm katie do
ba today we're gonna check out this
trailer for the intern starring Anne
Hathaway and yo Robert De Niro you son
of a [ __ ] show ah ah as far as my
dinero goes can't really say anything
else after it was enough it was enough
and Anne Hathaway who is Katie's
favorite actress apparently you know
what's weird about Anne Hathaway critics
lover award seasons tend to notice her
but I don't know anyone that actually
likes her she's very talented and
beautiful you're clearly a pathological
liar here Anne Hathaway is someone who
does get on my nerves until I'm watching
her and then I like her performance it's
weird I don't know why I have seen some
movies where I really liked her I think
it's just a style thing she just rubs me
the wrong way yeah she rubs me the right
way you know what I mean boom I rub
myself to her she doesn't do any of the
rubbing okay Benjamin I'm gonna ask you
one of our more telling questions for
all of our interns don't want to you
like this is the one to really think
about okay where you see yourself in ten
years why not maybe a few weeks ago we
talked about the senior intern program
seniors in high school or college no no
no seniors in life what any tips before
going blank one she hating people don't
blank it where's our outside tools and
then your new intern
I'm glad you also see the humor in this
be hard not to I will email you and I
have something for you to do I'll wait
to hear from you soon I'm totally sorry
excuse me
so your jewels new driver well actually
I'm enter the manager keeps busy mr.
congeniality everybody loves them you
should dress to impress tuck in the
shirt why doesn't anybody tuck anything
anymore you joined about ten minutes ago
well better late than never alright so
there are all these questions for your
profile that you can answer if you want
to like people to inspire you to
exhaustion you doing spy job our
investors just think that a seasoned CEO
could take some things off your plate
let me get me CEO lessons I didn't have
anything like this in my life this big
beautiful exciting thing that you
created remember who did that Oh
good time it's not like this when you
need something you know you can count on
because you're my future well I was
gonna say enter slash best friend
look and learn boys because this is what
cool is how a one generation have men
gone from guys like Jack Nicholson and
Harrison Ford to boy all right
yeah okay fine fine Anne Hathaway fine
that was charming I don't know like I
grew up with too much DeNiro I have a
hard time not seeing De Niro doing what
he's doing in this movie I don't know if
you know that like how to aware that he
is not doing what Robert De Niro is
usually kind of known for which is cool
but it doesn't necessarily feel like De
Niro has really allowed himself to fully
train it seems like he's having fun
but it doesn't seem like he's doing like
you know becoming the character or
something like that oh really really
like at times it did I don't know it
might have just been my first time
watching it I think that the same the
same people did it's complicated and
there was one other that they listed
there yeah something's got to give them
ah and those are right in the same vein
you know you have an older cast of
characters and the value of the that
generation and their sort of quirkiness
and their charm and there's no one
better for that than him I think maybe
like Steve Martin or Alec Baldwin or
Jack Nicholson those are the guys you
know they know how to wear a suit they
know how to get a shave they know how to
charm the ladies and like they're
endearing makes me think of like my
relationship with my mom it is just a
trailer but from seeing the trailer
alone I was like okay I can I can get on
board with De Niro but sometimes his
comedy and movie seems a little bit like
he's too aware he's making a joke like
the whole blinking bit to me I just
don't know that might have been the
rating though too
it might have been a bad idea no on the
nose I feel like when Nancy Meyers she
usually has more unique hooks in her
films you think about what women want
like this guy is able to read women's
minds something's got to give
deals with an interesting clash of old
dating young and
and then seeing perspectives on that
it's complicated deals with affairs but
to this point I don't really see
anything other than like it's another
intern story but he's a senior I feel
like Nancy Meyers is capable of
exploring better territory and more
interesting territory I wonder if
they'll release the second trailer
though because some most writers yeah
can be so simplified so maybe maybe the
movie will add that extra no I don't
that you know what I'm doing this is a
trailer and I'm judging the entire film
off of the trailer the trailer it why
should I watch a movie if the trailer is
just telling me exactly how it's going
to be guys you don't have to then I'll
watch it Katie I you are so good at
avoiding fights
I'm diplomatic that is that a type of
religion the trailer doesn't really
promote us an interesting enough
performance from Hanna Hathaway either
yeah it's a little bland from her but
maybe that's why I mean de niro's
playing like a simplistic guy I like
that I'm sure what De Niro all by him
when I'm actually watching the movie I'm
sure I've seen it seen see the same
thing that I had a the way the more I
think about this trailer which has been
at five minutes I realized that they
were probably just this is their
marketing trailer how are we gonna get
this to appeal we got to give it a vibe
other movies people like odd characters
in the office yeah like a beautiful
young boss let's start a humor but than
show it's gonna get a little bit serious
here but it's really about friendship
and like it seemed like a very marketing
traffic yeah exactly
anyway reading time I will wait to see a
second trailer before deciding to watch
the intern
I will probably also wait for a second
trailer okay no screen shot for you
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter where if we get
enough followers we can get product
placement for things such as mugs
glasses oh we're just gonna do multiple
products today hat I thought we were
just naming things no clearly you
haven't been watching the channel unless
you're in the episode the bit is I grab
a product and then I talk about it in
real good ways and then I punchline it
on it being somehow sexually relatable
but you're not selling the product in
any way no I could have said this Batman
mug is great because it can hold any
liquid and it can handle hot water
incredibly well and you know if you ever
want to pull a prank on someone you just
ejaculate in the water real fast tell
them it was like I don't know some sweet
and low and then they drink it and you
go ha you drank my [ __ ] mugs that could
have been the bed